the russian invasion of ukraine is
bringing back just a flood of memories
for those who escaped another atrocity
mary jane valezza shares how ukraine's
fight is hitting close to home for
holocaust survivors here
[Music]
as a child i remember
the soldiers with machine guns
i remember
the bombings valentina lund was only
five years old when she left ukraine as
a holocaust survivor she says the
situation in her home country is a
painful memory from her past they got
captured by the nazis and then they were
sent to
concentration camps lund still has
family in ukraine who are taking shelter
in her brother cellar i just started
running last week the russian
soldiers are now going house to house
and she's not the only one reliving this
nightmare it's happening in russia and
ukraine in a certain way it reminds me
back
in 1940s
when the nazis marched in and we didn't
know what we were facing stephen nasser
survived at the holocaust at 13. i lost
all my family
i was the only one survived but what's
happening today it's unbelievable while
the answer remains unclear of what will
happen with russia and ukraine both
nasser and lund agree we need to learn
from history so we don't repeat the past
how far are we going to stand and give a
hand to ukraine i do not know it's up to
the politicians but while they're
playing around with politics people are
dying day to day our faith is very
strong ukrainian faith is very strong
and that's one thing that keeps us going
keep going while never forgetting mary
jane boyezza live local now